So, the answer is many of the properties are
desirable. The second property is desirable. So, the first property
is not desirable. That if the hash function outputs a
unique number for every keyword, well then, the range for
the hash function would be very large. We'd need
a huge amount of memory to store the hash table.
And the number of buckets would be the same as
the number of keyboards. That's not going to work very well.
What we want is the number of buckets to be b, so
that means that the output of the hash function should be in
the range between 0 and b minus 1. That will find the
element of the list that corresponds to that bucket. So, we do want
the second property. The third and the fourth properties say that we
want the number of keywords in each bucket to be approximately the
same. So, if there are k keywords and we're fitting them into
b buckets, if we want the buckets to be approximately the same size,
then each bucket should have approximately k divided by b keywords.
So, both the third and the fourth property are true. The
final property says that we should have more keywords in bucket
zero than in bucket one. There's no reason that we would prefer
that, so you, you might think it would be better to
have more keywords at the beginning than later on, that's not
the case with a hash table. Remember, what our hash function
does is, it tells us right away which bucket to go through.
We don't have to look through the earlier buckets. This
is different from the list index that we started with.
Where the first one is the fastest one to find.
And the last one requires going through all the elements.
For the hash table, that's not the case. There's no
reason to prefer having more entries in bucket zero to
bucket one. What we really want is to try to
have all the buckets have approximately the same number of keywords.